Something else they did,
was they tracked the state of the hand.
So, what do you mean,
the state of the hand?
That's actually, you, I,
I encourage you to read the paper.
They did a couple of really cool things.
First of all, you have Translation.
Okay?
Well, how many degrees of freedom in
translation?
Well, we're doing it in two dimensions,
so there's two degrees of freedom.
They had a Rotation.
Okay.
Which is one degree of freedom.
But the other thing they added to
that was the shape of the hand.
And you might ask, well how did
they encode the shape of the hand.
Don't bother Megan.
Well actually what they did was they
took a whole bunch of images of
contours.
And then they did a form of
principle components analysis.
Now you may not know what that is.
But the good news is you will.
Very soon we're going to do principle
corner analysis when we talk about,
recognition.
The thing that matters is that it has
a low dimensional representation of,
certain variation.
And what they did is they
extracted out essentially,
instead of keeping rotation separately,
they took ten degrees of freedom
that represented the shape of
the hand including rotation.
So you had two for translation and
ten for rot, for the,
for the rotation and shape.
So, that's a 12 degree
of freedom of space.
So that's even more difficult to do the,
tracking with particles because you have
to have a lot of particles
in order to do this.